14 on your monday morning hey the animal
foundation offering free and discounted
pet adoptions for clear the shelters now
this national adoption campaign's all
about getting animals
into forever homes and our hector he is
live with everything you don't
need to know about the process sounds
like you've already got some new friends
there hector
yeah i've made quite a few friends here
this morning take a look this
is bonnie bonnie here is uh well let's
find out how old bonnie is i know she's
been here for
quite some time but she was astray this
is kelsey joining us live here at the
animal foundation
good morning to you good morning yeah we
love bonnie she is seven years old and i
think she's all ready for edc with her
little
she is ready tiggela come on so tell us
about bonnie she
listens to commands so she actually came
in as a stray but yes she does know
basic commands and she loves her treats
as you can see
i think she really likes you hector and
you know kelsey you know i've been
searching for a dog for a pet for many
months now
and tell us about the process for those
who are interested in doing the same
so right now is clear the shelters it is
the entire month of august so that means
dogs and cats six months and older the
adoption fee
is waived usually it's a one day event
and this year it is the entire month of
august so you can come down and meet
bonnie yourself you do need an
appointment because of covid that's how
things are operating here at the shelter
so we ask people to go online pick out a
pet like bonnie
and come down and meet them and uh
speaking of the pandemics so this event
normally would only be for just
a day and now it's taking the entire
month and that's because we want people
to have time to
come in here and make an appointment and
you know
find the right pet for them based on
what fits with their family
so for those who are thinking what's the
best thing for them to do to
check out the pets that are available
online check out the pets online and
make an appointment with our adoptions
team look how sweet she is this is
adorable
she is adorable if you're looking for a
pet like bonnie um
she would be a perfect couch potato a
quarantine buddy you know
weird times right now and your routine
might be thrown out the window
she's ready to play this will make you
happy at home if you're stuck at home if
you had bonnie on the couch with you
let's i say let's reward her with a
treat oh i love
bonnie let's find her at home all right
bonnie well you can uh meet other pets
like bonnie straight ahead in half an
hour
uh actually no in just a few minutes at
6 30. so for now reporting live hector
mejia
8 news now back to you guys um hector i
think that bonnie picked you
to be her dad that is a cute thing i
think
i think she did and um i would be the
lucky one to have her
oh how cute and i love her flowers
too